but this is an absolutely gigantic
development in the Trump Russia scandal
increasingly we've been looking at
Donald Trump's intent to build a Trump
Tower in Moscow everybody has had a
different story about how serious this
project ever was but more importantly
there have been a lot of denials about
how involved if at all Donald Trump was
we've heard months of denials in fact
denials that said Trump wasn't even
aware of the project being discussed
during the 2016 presidential campaign
months of denials that there are any
signed documents that that there's
anything more than the idea of Michael
Cohen sending a few emails about maybe
some day there could be a Trump Tower
Moscow build and that if there were any
such documents Donald Trump's name
definitely isn't on any of them Donald
Trump's signature more importantly more
accurately isn't on any of them it was
Trump's lawyer Michael Cohen who is
working on this or it was Ivanka and
Eric and Don Jr in any case Donald Trump
was totally out of this deal and not at
all involved except that we now have the
smoking gun that proves that Donald
Trump and his lawyer Rudy Giuliani and
all of them have been lying cNN has
obtained a letter of intent to build
Trump Tower Moscow signed by Donald
Trump with that stereotypical that
trademark huge sharpie signature of
Donald Trump's that we've talked about
before as a reminder before we play the
clip on Sunday just this past Sunday
Donald Trump's attorney Rudy Giuliani
said there is a document but Donald
Trump never signed the document a
document was drawn up never signed by
anybody
never mind by Donald Trump Giuliani
saying to Danna bash on CNN it was a
real estate project there was a letter
of intent to go forward but no one
signed it but then CNN found the letter
and it has been signed and it was signed
by Donald Trump himself take a look take
a look at this this is the letter of
intent
for the proposed Trump Tower Moscow all
right it is signed by Donald J Trump how
do I know well because we've been told
it was by his lawyer and it is and I'll
show it to you in a second now I want
you to take a walk down memory lane to
remind you of what the President himself
has said about this project first he
said there was no deal listen to this I
have nothing to do with Putin I have
nothing to do with Russia
I have nothing to do with Russia we have
nothing to do with Russia you know for a
deal that didn't mean anything it's a
lot of pages man with a lot of detail
about what they wanted and how they
wanted it and how he be paid and there's
a signature okay there it is that
distinctive thick sharpie signature and
once again
Rudolph the Red Nosed lawyer told
another lie and what we now have is
confirmation that Donald Trump signed
this recall that Trump knew the deal
involved the Kremlin because Michael
Cohen told him that it did we have proof
in writing Pat that Donald Trump was
doing business with active adversaries
of the United States while pushing the
most Pro Russia anti Ukraine policy in a
long time while lying about it as he
simultaneously ran for president of the
United States well we can definitely
call this a smoking gun because it's
clear-cut evidence you can see the guy's
signature on the document after all
that's as clear as it gets but it
doesn't go to any legal culpability it
just goes to show that they were lying
all along and now they've been caught in
the lie so that's the significance of
this I've said before and I will say it
again there's a very good chance that
this all does not get Donald Trump
removed from office it should but it
will likely not and that's an indictment
of our political system it should be
difficult to remove a president it
should because you don't want presidents
to be able to be removed merely for
political disagreements or political
ganging up on so to speak but if there
are no repercussions for effectively
negotiating away
foreign-policy with real estate deals
promises to Vladimir Putin of penthouse
condos then the United States is simply
not serious about the rule of law and of
democracy and we are just selling to the
highest bidder
which in many ways we've been doing for
decades that that's actually the reality
when will the Republicans come around
and say no more
this has to end this is not about
politics anymore this is about the
sovereignty of the United States where
are they going to get the testicular
fortitude
wink wink to do that when they are often
just scared of Donald Trump and the
effect that their reelection chances may
suffer as a result of coming out and
saying it will they ever
unfortunately Pat is probably right that
they won't but every aspect of every
single one of these stories the Trump
Tower meeting Trump Tower Moscow I could
list them for an hour we are being lied
to constantly and as yet there have been
no repercussions for the big players who
have been telling the lies send me your
thoughts as to their whether there ever
will be such repercussions I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show one of the
day's sponsors is privacy comm slash
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy calm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a david
pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration
date and security code are automatically
entered I can put in any zip code I want
and I'm done and if you try to use my
credit card number that you just saw on
the screen it doesn't matter because
I've already deleted that virtual card
and that's the beauty of privacy calm
there are a ton of advantages to using a
free service like this for example you
can sign up for as many free trials as
you want then just delete the virtual
credit card you used and never worry
about getting charged for it it protects
you from getting hacked it protects you
when companies are hacked which happens
all the time
it is all completely free all you have
to do is click the link under this video
to get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link